the whole reason for founding spacex was
to make humanity a multi-planetary
species
and this was partly motivated by
existential threats
like a third world war or a random
asteroid plummeting towards earth
settling on other planets or the moon
would definitely allow for the survival
of our species but it's not as easy as
packing up our stuff and immigrating to
another country elon musk
the founder of spacex has made his
vision with mars very clear he wants
cities on the red planet the settlements
would need large numbers of people to
become
self-sustaining to do that we need a
vehicle that can handle the task
and the starship rocket is the one for
the job it's a combination of a rocket
and a spacecraft that could ferry more
than 100 people at a time to mars
but does it really need to be that
gigantic
welcome back to our channel before we
dive in make sure you subscribe and ring
the bell so you get notified every time
we upload a video
at launch the spacecraft called starship
will sit on top of a rocket called super
heavy
yeah they could have gone further with
the name but the combined system will
stand at 120 meters
or 394 feet for some context that's
taller than the statue of liberty which
reaches 93 meters or 305 feet
the structure is about as tall as a
30-story building
the whole system together that is the
spacecraft and the rocket
is called starship but it's not all
about height if the vehicle is to
accommodate a hundred people
it has to be wide enough too it is nine
meters or 30 feet in diameter which is
about as wide as most apartments
assuming you don't live in a penthouse
it was designed to have a payload of 100
tons because
after all this starship is designed to
carry people and cargo to mars
and launch satellites to the lower earth
orbit but the satellite missions are
mostly a side quest the main aim is to
deliver enough materials and people to
mars to start building a civilization
there
let's look at the spacecraft first it
has a nose cone and
landing fins and it seems the developers
took their inspiration from older sci-fi
comic books at the rear of the 50-meter
long craft are six
raptor engines developed over the course
of 10 years by spacex combustion takes
place in stages
and the engine's efficient design cuts
the amount of propellant that's wasted
speaking of waste
starship is designed to be fully
reusable meaning the principal hardware
elements don't get thrown into the sea
or burnt up which is usually the case in
other launch systems they can be
recovered and then be refurbished and
flown again
reducing expenses for spacex towards the
middle of the vehicle
are the propellant tanks which feed
methyl locks to the raptors
metholox is a combination of liquid
nitrogen and liquid oxygen
methane is the fuel and the oxygen acts
as an oxidizer
a chemical that makes the fuel burn
typically rockets don't use methylx for
fuel but methane can generate plenty of
thrust and it can be synthesized from
martian subsurface water
and from the atmospheric carbon dioxide
using a sabatier reaction
that means starship can be easily
refueled on mars for the return trip to
earth that would essentially be the
first step to making mars
self-sufficient the front of the
spacecraft which is often called the
upper stage
contains the huge payload compartment
that will haul large cargo
or carry people to their destination now
let's talk about the rocket the super
heavy
it measures 70 meters or 230 feet
and will be filled with 6.8 million
pounds of cryogenic methylox
it will be powered by 28 raptor engines
providing a whopping 16 million pounds
of maximum thrust
it should be able to lift at least 100
tons of payload and possibly 150 tons to
the low earth orbit
if we compare this to other rockets we
have sent to space everything else
pretty much pales in comparison the
legendary saturn v
stands at 110 meters nasa's sls block 2
cargo
stands at 111 meters and starship trumps
both of them in height payload and
specifications
long-haul trips to mars and back will
take nine months each way
which means you're going to need plenty
of entertainment aboard along with the
40 cabins which will be in the payload
area
there will be common rooms a galley a
shelter from where you can watch solar
storms
a theater and a lecture hall each cabin
could room five or six people if you
don't mind a small crowd
if not then two to three people can
share this space comfortably
in 2017 elon musk revealed his bigger
plan for mars
to get one million people to the red
planet for colonization
and to carry those many people plus
enough food and materials to sustain
them on the red planet
you're going to need a gigantic space
shuttle but before they blast off to
mars they will also play a role in
nasa's artemis program which aims to
establish a human colony on the moon
spacex received 135 million dollars from
nasa to fund their starship vehicle so
it could be used to take their crew to
the moon
so by now you're probably seeing why
starship needs to be
so big they had a test launch and
landing just this month when they sent
the prototype six miles above texas
making this its fifth launch since
december and unlike the four
before it this one landed smoothly and
didn't blow up after spending a few
minutes back on earth the previous one
exploded 10 minutes after landing
after a fire burning around it wouldn't
go out but it's not all about having
room for people or carrying a huge
payload to understand
starship's massive size you have to
understand the economies of scale
spacex abandoned the more expensive and
complex carbon fiber material for a
special alloy of stainless steel
the reason that works better is steel
performs better in the heat which is
created when you re-enter the orbit
at 20 000 miles per hour going from an
absolute vacuum to a planet's atmosphere
is like taking a glass dish out of the
oven and shoving it into the freezer
the air molecules cause incredible
amounts of friction and heat while any
other material would require heat
reflecting tiles a stainless steel body
will be mostly unaffected
spacex is also working on optimizing
their whole process of manufacturing
and supply chains to make sure the
stainless steel alloy is as cost
effective as can be
and let's not forget the ship can run
dozens of missions with minimal
maintenance
so the overall costs in the long run are
reduced by quite a lot
of course the cost of fuel required to
power this rocket will be astronomical
no pun intended but it is offset by its
other capabilities which is why a bigger
craft makes more economical sense but
there's much more to this than economics
before looking at reusable rockets
humans mostly left space
junk and decommissioned satellites in
designated graveyards
it's just a waste but now we're evolving
and learning to clean up our
acts we started with inefficient fossil
fuel burning transport systems
and now we're slowly moving to electric
starship is the new way of doing
interplanetary transport we may soon go
from having one launch
every year or every two years to
possibly having regular summer vacations
on the moon
or having commercial flights to mars but
starting on the process
isn't as easy as hitting a big red
button and watching the rocket launch
there are some hurdles spacex will have
to overcome and it partly has to do with
a massive size of starship
their test launches with this 120 meter
tall behemoth will require a new type of
license from the federal aviation
administration
which involves many regulatory hurdles
and an environmental assessment
depending on the fundings of that
assessment it's possible spacex will
have to conduct a new environmental
impact statement which could take up to
three years
to fuel this giant some reports say
spacex has been tapping into natural gas
wells
and building power plants in boca chica
which could also prolong their
environmental review
does this complicate matters yeah
definitely but elon musk is nothing if
not an optimist with some very ambitious
timelines
so while there will undoubtedly be
delays in our colonization of the red
planet there is no doubt that it will
definitely happen
think you'll pay a visit to the red
planet on starship let us know in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
hit the like button and check out more
videos just like this on the space tech
channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time